la audiencia del expresidente estuvo
presidida de todo un debate muy teórico
acerca de la necesidad de que el
declarará en este proceso se oponían
sobre todo los abogados de la defensa de
los catorce acusados ellos decían que el
expresidente no tenía nada que aportar
para el conocimiento de la verdad que su
presencia aquí era una politización de
este proceso y se oponían también porque
él recordemos estaba en el estado de
francia esa noche del 13 de noviembre y
en cambio en este proceso ninguna de las
partes civiles del estadio fueron
acogidas sin embargo el presidente de la
corte ya lupe ariel decidió que el ex
presidente debía testimoniar recordemos
que él fue invitado por una asociación
de víctimas y justamente cuando comenzó
su discurso preliminar el ex mandatario
recordaba que estaba aquí porque se lo
debía a las víctimas françois hollande
dijo que los ataques del 13 de noviembre
y esto en respuesta hasta la caf de esla
en el único sobreviviente de los
comandos del 13 de noviembre no fueron
planificados como una respuesta a la
intervención francesa en síria pues dijo
los atentados comenzaron mucho antes y
si todo por ejemplo el desaliento
en el tren de thalys él dijo que en
realidad lo que habían atacado los
terroristas era el estilo de vida
francés una república laica donde se
privilegia el amor por la cultura y el
deporte cuando se le preguntó si él
estaba arrepentido de esa decisión de
haber autorizado esos bombardeos en sí y
él dijo que nunca se había arrepentido
que si tuviera que decidirlo de nuevo lo
haría pues esa decisión la tomó cuando
supo que en siria había campos de
entrenamiento donde se estaban
preparando personas para hacer la guerra
en francia françois hollande o también
dijo que los servicios de inteligencia y
de seguridad hicieron lo máximo posible
pero no pudimos evitar los atentados de
cuando tuvimos la información para
evitarlos obviamente un atentado es un
fracaso pero el ex presidente se
preguntó cuántos otros no fueron
frustrados